you're good at doing this which is you
identify these lifestyle trends you like
pick up pretty quickly on like there's a
group of people that are deciding to
like live under a different paradigm or
different motto or creed
and actually that's always like one of
the best ways to build a business around
that lifestyle because you can speak to
that audience you can differentiate a
product super easily to that crowd
[Music]
dude have you ever been inside factories
you probably have but i think most
people have have you been inside like
any kind of why do you think that i've
been in the factory
you're going to be like i don't know
like my [__] cousin bubba has like a
bubble gum factory and you're going to
be like
i went fishing for i went fishing
recently with my father-in-law and he's
like hey so how do i set this hook up
what do i do i'm like dude i don't know
i've never gone fishing he's like why
don't you just assume that i know how to
do this dude you look like a guy
you just look like you seem for sure
like a guy who's gonna
i've watched documentaries on it
do you or do you not have a favorite
place to fish
no
of course i don't have a fishing hole
that i go to
um but no i've i've i don't think i've
been to a factory not really like what
type of factory it doesn't matter any
factory whatever factory you go into
it's [__] mind-blowing how like even
to go to a warehouse like go to every
you've been inside like an amazon
warehouse or like a yeah like a food
warehouse like how the food gets to
restaurants um it's insane in the same
way that like going to a farm is like
slightly crazy and you're like whoa
i eat these these i eat these animals
like oh wow uh you know that doesn't
seem right
but like
basically a factory it is kind of
stunning
like if you take any object on like okay
i am holding this microphone this is
sitting on my this is the foam
cover of a microphone there's some like
huge factory that like is churning them
out if you just go back trace the
process of how this got to my desk so
okay i just go on amazon i just
microphone uh i don't know maybe this
one i click that i buy it right so it
goes from an amazon warehouse onto a
like amazon warehouse packs it into a
carrier carrier brings it to my house
puts the package on my doorstep okay
great how did it get to the amazon
warehouse well first it was in probably
like another warehouse before it even
got sent to amazon before that warehouse
it was in a factory being made by human
beings all right so actually before that
before it got to the warehouse it was on
a boat in a container
like sailing from [__] china
on a boat with human beings just living
on the boat as it sails for months you
know two months to to the coast
and then it gets like un you know like
docked and separated out of a container
ship and like humans beings are there in
the factory there's human beings you
know i don't know how how many you know
small children died making this foam
cover but it's like the amount of
work that goes into
everything that's sitting in our house
just arriving there is insane to me like
just the materials so where did the
material for this foam come from right
there's like a
you know if you have cotton right that
starts in a field somewhere it gets puck
it gets plucked and it's pulled and it
gets processed then it gets shipped and
then it gets
manufactured then it gets printed then
it gets manufactured again it's like
that is insane
yeah
to the point where i'm kind of like
we're kind of ruining the earth and also
people's lives like you know like
to get i can't feel my t-shirt well i
cancelled my amazon prime membership i
was like man i feel guilty
i order something and it's like so much
energy behind the scenes when to ship
this of course i only see they ship a
dongle to a computer a small ass thing
with
bubble wrap in a huge box and i'm like
oh this is horrible and then i have to
pay money to pay a truck to come pick it
up because i it's too much you know by
constant yeah
yeah then the truck you know burns gas
and then takes it somewhere else and
[__] dumps it somewhere and then
someone else's problem right like so
it's just kind of like on one hand i'm
amazed that the system even works like
the fact that the package
gets from the factory in vietnam
to the warehouse and then you go to the
warehouse and there's like an
unbelievable number of boxes and then
they get sort of picked and packed into
the package and that gets shipped and
you if you ever go to the post office
like if you go to the post office and
you you should just ask them be like hey
can i see what it's like behind the the
door there they'd be like what why i
just never seen a post office they'll
open the door it is like santa's like
you know elves factory basically it's
like the most unbelievable number of
packages and you're like where's the
system like aren't there conveyor belts
and they're like no we just got these
like trolleys and then we just kind of
keep them like you know the ones going
over there they stay over in this area
then we hope we don't lose them it's
like
wow this is insane that this system even
works it is pretty crazy it's like an
incredible achievement
it's crazy you can mail something from
california to new york for like 45 cents
and it gets there in like four days yeah
that's what i'm saying pretty reliably
so i'm like it is on one hand amazing
and on the other hand is horrifying
the amount of like i forget the
environmental side right i'm not even
that environmentally conscious it's not
like something that i think about all
the time or i feel super guilty about
i actually feel more like the human
energy and labor and just the amount of
effort and resources it took to get this
thing to me it makes me think like you
know we had that guy david friedberg
come on the pod you you weren't there
for that one but the thing he's doing
which is basically like hey
he's doing the same thing in the drink
industry which is like instead of
you know
putting 20 liters of water to grow
grapes then crush the grapes turn it
into wine add sugar add alcohol pack it
up put it to a you know send it to a
bottling factory then send it to a
warehouse then put it on a shelf and a
store and then drive it home and put it
on a shelf in your home like he's like
why don't you just like manufacture it
in your home using this little printer
that'll print a drink for you
and um
and it's like oh yeah that cuts out like
90 percent of like the the you know this
like energy and like kind of resources
and time and effort that goes into
bringing this drink to my you know you
know to be able to drink this drink so i
just feel like more than ever that was
like that was the big wake-up call that
was my going into space moment
was realizing
for every single product every shirt
every pair of boxers every sock that i
own
how much goddamn like effort labor
travel
resources goes into it and realizing
that that's not gonna be the way
um that's not gonna be the way forever
and like this kind of like 3d printing
you know like sort of basically
manufacturing just in time at the end
point and cutting out a whole bunch of
these like factories and warehouses and
all that other stuff
that needs to happen was my big wake-up
call i want to ask you about then what
else is there that you can do that for
but before that have you ever gotten
into the buy it for life movement you
have i told you about that
um no but i think i understand it from
that what is it it's like an
eco-friendly way of like buying yeah
well i don't it doesn't have to be
rooted in eco-friendly uh it's not for
me but it's a perk there's a subreddit
that i subscribe to it's called buy it
for life and
what you do is the the idea is just how
do you just consume less stuff and how
do you just buy the best of something
that hopefully can last forever so an
example
uh do you remember as a kid did your mom
ever have a kitchenaid mixer
yes
okay so kitchenaid mixer kitchenaid's a
brand the mixer like it's the thing with
the bowl underneath it and like the arm
that goes above it and spins those are
like six hundred dollars they're really
expensive
but they're famous for lasting like a
lifetime like you can use an antique one
and it works just as good and another
example is if you're gonna buy like a a
coat like there's like um you can maybe
buy a really fancy leather coat and
you're willing to spend two thousand
dollars as opposed to buying a 300 one
because it could like last forever as
long as you fit in it or patagonia it
actually does that too they'll fix your
stuff forever or um there's like a bunch
of furniture there's a bunch of shoes
like different types of shoes you can
buy it instead of them whenever they
wear down instead of throwing throwing
them away you can just get them fixed
and so it's the idea of like how do you
buy one thing forever and it hopefully
can last forever
or buy one thing one time and it'll last
forever i feel like you do stuff like
this ben do you do you have like objects
that you uh
stuff that you buy that's like meant to
to sort of last i don't know why my
hunch just tells me you do the funny
thing is my dad does this but not out of
like um like environmental justice ideas
but just like
because he's crazy that way of like he
drove the same car for 22 years and just
like couldn't bring himself to buy a new
car
and always shines his shoes because he's
owned the same shoes for like 40 years
and so that like kind of got ingrained
in me as like a good way to live and so
i do do this a little bit
it's awesome it's fun and also like some
of your [__] as you wear it patinas it
actually looks cooler
right
now you're good at doing this which is
you identify these like lifestyle trends
it's like do you know there's some
people that are like you know not eating
food anymore they're just drinking
whatever uh soylent or you know like
you know there's people that just micro
dose lsd every day and like these are
kind of famous examples now but i feel
like you've told me about like 30 of
these in the time that we've been
friends and they're like dude have you
seen this like you know subreddit called
you know fat fire or whatever it's like
you always have these like
you you like pick up pretty quickly on
like there's this weird
not even weird it's just like there's a
group of people that are deciding to
like live under a different sort of like
paradigm or different motto or creed and
actually that i think you just like
because it's interesting but that also
is like one of the best ways to build a
business around that lifestyle because
you can speak to that audience you could
differentiate differentiate a product
super easily to that crowd and i i seek
the i seek those things out so there's a
bunch of things that i i don't agree
with or i don't i don't want to live my
life that way but i love just like
seeing it i like seeing how
basically i love freaks i like weirdos i
consider myself a weirdo and i love a
good freak show i just love i'll see it
like i remember the first time like
three years ago i went to my friend's
house and he didn't have a microwave i'm
like what you know microwave he's like
well it's bad for this reasons and i was
like you're a freak like mike we all
have microwaves you're the weirdo and
then you start thinking about i'm like
well okay tell me why why do you think
you might be right and i'm like okay
maybe there's a point there or like uh
my friends a lot of my friends now
refuse to use plastic tupperware or
plastic anything that you eat with and
i'm like well why i just put my thing in
microwave who cares and so like there's
a bunch of little things like that that
i love learning about
yeah i remember when justin mirrors came
on you you were like let me guess you
don't have a microwave in your house
he's like yep and i was like that's a
[__] weird spot-on question to ask
somebody that i don't think you knew the
answer to ahead of time and then that
got me thinking about that this this
exact lifestyle you're talking about in
fact moyes um so moyes started native
deodorant which was around one of these
trends which was
people wanted an all-natural
paraben-free aluminum-free deodorant and
he saw that on etsy that was like a
really high selling item but it was like
in the etsy kind of handmade artisan
goods like bubble
and his bet was that people once you
kind of speak to that value system of
like not having x they might be willing
to pay more and be become a like switch
deodorant brands if you like built a
brand around it
he recently tweeted something he goes
billion dollar idea
water that has not touched plastic so
it's a water brand that has only been
like in glass containers or like you
know basically like from the
whatever the mountain that this was
gotten it hasn't touched plastic until
it's reached your lips
and um
and i thought that was funny it's like
this this plastic thing is is
uh real a lot of people are anti
plastics uh yeah so that means like for
every product where plastic is core
there's going to be a alt product where
plastic is not not like not used so
whether it's tupperware or like for me i
drink water out of you know we get those
big five gallon jugs or whatever
delivered the house out of a dispenser
that that's a plastic container it's
sitting in the whole time until i drink
it right so it's just a giant water
bottle and so there's like
there's there's these trends where you
can look at okay where is there like if
there's an anti-plastic tran where is
there plastic and can i create an
alternative if there's a plant-based
vegan trend
how do i make alt milks alt meat alt
whatever right that becomes like a
blueprint to building a great business
so there's a few companies out right now
you might know their names i'm going to
try and look them up but basically
uh there's this trend amongst
products that you use daily that you run
out of so like toothpaste laundry
detergent
uh
advil bottles things where
the bottle isn't is just like a way to
get it to you but it's kind of [__]
that you have to throw it away and so
they're making all these products where
they send you one package
and then they send you like whenever you
need it just a re something to refill it
like lit or like literally something you
pour into it um do you know what they're
called you know what i'm talking about
but i've seen this for toothpaste um
and i think it's a great idea i think
this is incredible i love it there's
this idea
um and i at first i thought it was small
i think moyes was the one who told me
i'm pretty sure he said it's like
killing it um you don't know what i'm
talking about i forget what it is uh
no i don't know the name uh i'll have to
look up what it is but
they're crushing it i know there's like
um four cleaners i think there's one
called blue land i think doesn't blue
land do this is it blue yeah i know
you're talking about yeah and it's like
chemical free containers and then they
send you one container and then they
you you order something and they i don't
know exactly how they send it to you but
you just like pour it into the thing
right
send you a plastic pouch that you throw
away yeah
yeah i think it's like less less bad
um
by the way speaking of these kind of
like niche crazy people i got two for
you so one
is
we talked i think about um anti-r
anti-work did we talk about that on the
podcast i don't know i don't think we
talked about it but it pisses me off
so there's r anti-work
which you should explain that and then i
have another one that's the the counter
to it so first explain anti-work i don't
even entirely know how to explain it it
was i'll tell you the background from
what if i remember correctly it was
started eight years ago but uh like in
the last three years since the pandemic
is when it really got popular it was
made up of a lot of people who were
waiters and waitresses and they were
pissed off at how they were being
treated and it started out as like a
labor movement thing like we need higher
wages we need this now it's like got 8
million 10 million subscribers on the
subreddit and it's people complaining
about like you know my manager said that
like they fired me because i told them i
was busy when i needed to come in and
they just basically [__] on anything
where it's like demanding of of workers
and so i think so so here's their here's
i think their stated thing ben you tell
me if i'm being too harsh on it if you
find a more generous explanation but
here's what it says it is a subreddit
for those who want to end work are
curious about ending work and want to
get the most out of a work-free life the
subreddit has cracked over 1.4 million
members by the end of 2019 which has got
to be a lot more than that by now it's
eight million now and it went
it was one point oh my god
i think one went
viral after
a warehouse worker posted a screenshot
of a text that they sent their boss and
then that basically made other
workers the other workers like kind of
like saw that where inspired did the
same and it was part of this like you
know the great resignation that people
were talking about and there was like
this funny clip where they put they took
a mod from arsenal's anti-work and they
went on fox news i don't know have you
seen it yeah and this the person got
destroyed it was embarrassing
it's like anti-work person gets
destroyed by you know fox anchors like
the video which i didn't like
i hate when they do that this person
clearly like is not that smart i think
and like it's very easy to set them up
to look silly in that in those cases
the subreddit also didn't like it
because they were like dude horrible
representation of us
on tv
um did not articulate our points
and um you know why did you go on there
like this movement is not about you
getting your personal fame you know to
like do this
um
we kind of i think they had some rules
around like we're not going to do
appearances or speak to the media unless
we kind of agree on what the message is
um and so this person went rogue i guess
and did that but but they basically
embarrassed themselves but they were
like yeah i just don't want to work and
then guys like okay cool so like you
know you don't want to work at all or
like no i like i want to be able to do
what i want to do so what do you want to
do it's like i want to teach people i is
going to be i want to be a teacher
and he's like you want to be you want to
be a teacher you know should we let you
teach basically was kind of like the
the end point that they were kind of
making
but anyway so this there's anti-work
which went viral then there's have you
seen r overworked
no what's that it's the exact opposite
it's people who are using the pandemic
that kind of remote work lifestyle to be
like they call it having the multiple
jobs at once
so um like their lingo is like oh yeah
my j1 which is like my job one it's like
j1 has great benefits and so i'm just
picking up my j2
and j2 i'm just going to do 10 hours a
week with this this and this and i'm
going to use that to invest in these
things right so it's people scheming
together about how to work multiple jobs
at once
and as remote workers
oftentimes it seems like without the
employers knowing that there are other
jobs so they're like being
simultaneously employed without being
super overt about i think that's the
message i could be wrong on that
and um it's people who are trying to get
to financial freedom faster by saying
like yeah like actually
i have the capacity to do
like multiple jobs
um you know instead of sort of spending
40 hours a week on one job it's like i
can actually do a good job in 20 hours a
week on two jobs and get paid
that's the optimistic way to look at it
the probably realistic way like i'm
looking at the top title and it says
j my j3 job forgot about me today and
they say i started my j3 yesterday if i
started i mean i was giving an
orientation on zoom and no one showed up
so now i'm just sitting here on the
payroll right yeah yeah there's other
people are like yeah let's beat the
system
um
and so there's like basically a counter
movement but that kind of always happens
there's like a there's like the movement
and then there's the counter movement
that comes shortly after and like it
kind of polarizes and then there's a
mainstream which just does things the
way they've been doing them and they
don't really pay too much attention to
this stuff
and so um you know that that's kind of
common for
for many many uh many many of these
movements i think subreddits are a great
place to look for that
[Music]
you